hi and welcome to another edition of The
Gadget Lab podcast I'm Michael colori
I'm ma I'm my guys a good lord man
there's smoke coming out of your face
there's no smoking in the studio is that
hey I can smoke in the studio actually
because i'm using my e-cigarette made by
square square the the iphone card swipe
before not to be confused with the
mobile payment system this is a square e
cigarette so that i don't know if
there's a copyright problem or whatever
with the name but these guys make
basically disposable cigarettes that you
can that take the place of actual
cigarettes for about like it gets two
packs worth it lasts for 500 puffs 500
puffs yeah 52 x apparently so one of
these this is the this is the green one
it's not what you're thinking it's
actually menthol menthol this this so
this is about the same as two packs of
smokes yeah apparently and it costs it
costs 10 bucks so depending on where you
live that could be about the cost of two
packs if you're in New York probably not
in the big city they're about 750 so so
it's so it's a deal but so you don't
this isn't one where you put the
Chargers in this is one where you just
use smoke smoke smoke and then you throw
it away when it's done that's great yeah
and your smoke smoke smoking so it's not
actually smoke oh right it's like a
vaporizer yeah it's it's that's exactly
what's in there there's a little
vaporizer in here and it it's there's no
tar there's no secondhand smoke that
goes out and it's a it's a mixture of
what is it orchid flower fragrance
coriander water propylene so all the
delicious things that you can all of
these central oi right then go great
with tobacco I mean I guess supposedly
it's supposed to be better for you
because there's no tar but I mean there
are cigarettes out there that we won't
go anywhere near making any
was about now and I don't know if it's
supposed to be a substitute right i mean
i i'm a smoker and so I that was why I
was chosen to test this product
specifically and I still want to smoke
right but it kind of it's kind of like
nicotine gum right that there's a little
bit of a cloying bite at the back of
your throat whenever you chew it or
smoke it and you can maybe I maybe don't
have the urge to go downstairs and have
to smoke but I don't see the stake in
the place of like cigarettes from me
long term is it just is it just lately
there's like that whole thing about
drawing through the cigarette like the
ritual of it is that what you still miss
right I think oh i think there's part of
that you know like this that kind of
sates that right for the immediate term
like if you if you have to smoke if
you're on an airplane apparently it's
legal to smoke e-cigarette if you bust
one of these things out or an airplane
whoever Cyril Marshall to come yeah i
will pay you five dollars especially the
green one no no no it's totally cool so
it's cool to do it on airplanes
apparently it's cool they're doing it
I've never seen anyone actually do it
and not getting weird looks from
everyone around them so I don't know how
this it definitely looks weird there's a
little button yeah you press the button
and you inhale and it doesn't make any
noise and it fills your lungs with sweet
sweet tobacco vapor so smoking is not
cool by the way just so you know and
we're not advocating it neither am i
advocating anyone start smoking this is
just a sort of I guess it's a cool thing
that okay you can smoke in door you can
smoke on a plane whatever yep it's a
nice novelty for the smoker in your life
right you know what else is smoking what
is that make the news this week that
Facebook is having its IPO Facebook did
file for exact time so this has nothing
to do with gadgets but we felt like it
was important to talk about because
facebook is one of those things it
extends into basically every part of the
technology ecosystem there in our phones
there on our laptops there in our
conversations and now they're in your
podcast so when can i buy facebook stock
so they filed for their IPO on thursday
this
week so that means basically that
they're planning to go public that's all
the initial paperwork to kind of set the
wheels in motion it's gonna be probably
around may may I believe say that till
it actually makes its stock exchange
debut i believe it's on the nasdaq but
i'm not exactly sure what's their ticker
gonna be SLP and not suck FZ I want it
to be face face so it's like if he had a
bad stock market day face yeah yeah sell
face my face but it's in my face right
parts of the world with a big thing I
rang wake up in a bathtub with our face
no I was thinking like um reputation oh
that's uh we'll be able to you're gonna
just came to these things if that's cool
guys it's just water or something I sway
uh it does no it does have a pleasant
aroma yeah well it's this one's fruit
punch and that one's mental anyway if
you're a baller and have some Facebook
IPO stock in a few in a few months you
can smoke on of these is also left it's
probably it's probably gonna debut
facebook is estimating around thirty
percent 30 bucks per share something
like that thirty dollars a share right
the most interesting part though I think
which does actually relate to gadgets
half of the visits that Facebook had a
December war on mobile devices right
we're on SMO phone smartphones and
tablets that's that's insane because I
mean all out of the 845 million visits
they and descenders unique visits half
of that was on mobile when I'm when I'm
riding the bus and I look around because
that's all I do is I look at what other
people do on their phones around me
right um everybody's on Facebook right
there's like one guy a google reader and
then the other 30 people are all on
facebook right right so anyway we're
going to move along we're going to show
you a device that is a 3d printer but
unlike most 3d printers which use some
sort of polymer glue to print out the
physical objects of your desire this one
uses food sorrow and green yeah sweet
its people its people
my name is HOD Lipson I may associate
professor at mechanical aerospace
engineering department here at Cornell
University we do research in various
aspects of Robotics but we also have
been exploring lots of different New
Directions in design and manufacture of
other things which is how we got to this
whole area of 3d printing the fab at
home is an open hardware 3d printer and
it's the only 3d printer that can use a
wide variety of material so you can
print anything from cookies to play
dough to silicone stainless steel epoxy
clay and anything else your heart can
desire we gave the machine away the
designs away for free online people
start building their own and after they
were done 3d printing with silicone they
decided what other GU do I have laying
around the house and the answer is
peanut butter and nutella easy cheese we
started using food materials initially
as kind of structural support materials
you know we use the frosting as support
material because it dissolves in water
and so forth these are very kind of
useful structural properties then we
went on a little tangent and decided to
experiment with hydrocolloids they're
nice fun materials it's actually the
same materials we use for 3d printing
living tissue which we also do on this
machine we try to build foods from the
ground up where we would control the
texture with the hydrocolloids flavoring
agents for the flavors and add in
vitamin so you can imagine you know dial
in your hamburger and it also gives you
your lipitor medication and everything
you need and builds a fake hamburger
from the ground up we just forgot one
fundamental rule of cooking which is
that you should cook with food and we
went back to the drawing board and with
the help of Chef David Arnold we started
working on modifying traditional foods
anything from cheese and pesto to pasta
to frosting peanut butter chocolate
scallops that we printed into space
shuttles and deep-fried cubes of turkey
with cubes of celery paste on the inside
bri OS with anything that you can push
through a syringe but my personal
favorite is a new form of deep fried
corn we developed today we're going to
be making gears that are stochastically
printed to have this nice open pore
structure the tools you're going to need
are 3d printer and the deep fryer and
the ingredients are half a cup of corn
dough and a little bit more than
three-quarters a cup of water and mix it
in the bowl
push it together
it should have a nice consistency where
we'll stick to itself just a little but
only to itself then we'll take canister
just kind of press it into the back
making sure to leave the tip open to the
air can escape
you just put it right on the mission so
let's make us some nice deep fried masa
so we'll make it in the shape of a gear
so just type it in try giving to play
small scale it up to size it should work
then we click go
right now it's doing a process we call
stochastic training where it exploits a
material property no notice this gets
the right instability if you drizzle
it'll buckle and weave underneath the
spot where you're cruising so here we
use that to make spiral patterns to
build up more porks 3d printable
structures and when you make a porous
food structure out of say something like
corn dough which is an actually porous
you now can deep fry the entire thing
all the way through or if you use
another material you can imagine making
a filter out of this for even just
changing the mechanical properties of
this bulk material by introducing this
unstructured pattern to it
you
so now I'm going to take it and deep-fry
it so it can get nice and crispy you
could also bake it or just let it dry
out so it would firm up with it
it's done popping don't pull it out
it's completely at home doable it'll be
in restaurants it'll be in homes and
it'll be used for automating food
preparation but it'll be used for more
than that i'll give you control over
your food so maybe you like cookies that
are a little extra crispy on the outside
and be able to go into your application
tell it how much you want crispiness
you'll automatically make the cookie the
way you want or you can record grandma's
recipe and how she drew out individual
treats for the family dinner and then a
hundred years from now your great grand
kids can be 3d printing out the same
exact recipe with the same exact motions
this will be a kind of home appliance
that will be it will be difficult to
explain how we live without it so if you
could print out anything from food would
you print foie gras foie gras yeah you
put foie gras have a matter the shape
I'd burn hundred-dollar bills to light
my cigarette so I want to put foie gras
to let your e-cigarette like my
e-cigarette i would probably put in
lobster and have it print out like
nachos or something so you have to put
food in and then it puts it makes the
objects from food yeah did you ever see
that Simpsons lobster stuffed with tacos
yes it was really good uh hey speaking
of tacos you were down in Southern
California earlier this week in my
hometown of Dana Point California yours
beautiful at the ritz-carlton that's
correct also beautiful they retweeted me
earlier this week the Ritz the Ritz did
yeah what do you say nasty things about
no I said something very nice i said how
nice it wasn't yeah the champagne is
excellent anyway i was i was out there
for the the all things digital dive into
media conference where basically they're
taking a survey of the media landscape
right now so they had people from
youtube seller come on gar who's a
senior vice president there they had
guys from hulu they had dick costolo
from twitter and and the crown
achievement they had Neil Young himself
there so he had some nasty things to say
and some interesting things to say about
the state of digital music right
basically what you listen to his crap
and it's not the content itself it's the
quality of the content itself right so
he's from this generation where you know
they grew up with hifi sort of you know
listening to vinyl listening to this
pure if you want to call it that audio
experience where I'll go there and now
and now and now we are used to our
itunes 256k 50 best at best right
exactly they raised it up from 128
before right and mr. young is basically
saying that's crap right and we need to
change that and there needs to be
something some sort of service to push
those maybe better high quality files
out to and the new hardware device right
right exactly so that was actually my
favorite part about your story about the
Neil Young spiel was that there are he
had been talking you know talking he
doesn't really go into detail ok to
Steve Jobs before Steve passed away
about creating a newer version of the
ipod like an audiophile device and he
mentioned that when Steve goes home and
listens to music at the end of the day
when he was still working and alive he
would play vinyl and he would only this
you prefer to listen to vinyl so it's
just kind of interesting that the man
credited with you know spearheading the
digital music revolution found his own
device in his own ecosystem inadequate
for his taste in music was me yeah um
now I am also one of those people who
understands that the iPhone the iPad is
is not an audiophile device right I am
an audio file in that I appreciate my
love good sound and I have a very nice
stereo system a couple of them but you
know it's Neil's big point was it for a
very long time we've been trading the
convenience of downloading music and
carrying it around in our pocket while
sitting to it on her ear buds for
quality so we make a trade-off there and
he's tired of having to make that
trade-off you do something that's worth
it right exactly he actually took a shot
at dre and jimmy iovine too oh yeah the
beats he's on my team with beats I like
that when Neil Young is agreeing with
you about something that's pretty long
I'm also into his theory about domestic
electrics taking over the world
think that we're going to see a lot more
domestic electrics of course I'm talking
about Clara's gonna say are you putting
your band no no this the cars Neil's
real big car guy at once you want to see
Detroit go electric but he also wants to
see the whole music industry started
racing hi def audio and this is
something like being like the audio nerd
in the room and most of the functions
that I go to buy functions i mean like
hanging out with my friends and weekends
ours yeah a lot of people always ask me
well you know how do I make my music
sound better and my answer usually is
going itunes and crank up your mp3
Ripper to the highest possible setting
yeah which is 320 k right 3 20 in there
okay yeah so you just you crank it up as
high as high as it'll go and to most
people that high quality which is better
than what you get at the iTunes Store
remind you is you know indistinguishable
from CD quality to most people on most
equipment but what about the discerning
kind of sewers such as yourself and mr.
young well there are options you can rip
in apple lossless format iTunes will
also rip an apple lossless your files
will be much bigger and you can play
them back on your on your iPod or iPad
or whatever smartphone you have with the
correct software you can play lossless
audio files both a lacs and flac s which
is the open source you know pretty much
the same thing the open source lossless
format that's a trade-off in terms of
science right right so you have a much
bigger file but it does sound better it
is it is as good as CD quality it is
essentially the same thing as listening
to the CD as far as I be equality is
concerned but you can't buy those from
itunes you have to go to different
stores to buy lossless audio so you have
to go places like HD tracks or you have
to buy songs directly from the bands
like Radiohead sells flax bands can sell
flax on bandcamp you know the Beatles
have been selling flack versions of the
music outside of the United
gates George Harrison you can buy a copy
of all things must pass remastered on
lossless audio the nice thing about
these lossless file formats is that they
also allow you to listen to audio at
greater than CD quality one step above
that is something that's been around for
a while but it's just now starting to
make inroads which is direct stream
digital DSD files these are massive
files they also very expensive they've
got five dollars of track and you need
special software special equipment to
play it back although not that special
because the software from Korg that you
used playback DSD files is free and you
can playback DSD files on a Playstation
3 if you have one if you don't have a
ps3 and you're not in coorg software
then you're pretty limited with what you
can do with those high resolution
formats but the point is those high
resolution formats are out there they do
exist they do exist a lot of people are
getting into flat now because big name
artists are offering them and big
services are offering them but Neil's
beef which is the same beef that I it's
a very valid beef is that the main
ecosystem that everybody is bought into
already does not yet support these
things and that's what he's trying to
change so at least making it an option
for people sort of thing rather than I
mean obviously it's not going to be
priority for the mass the masses right
right i just want to hear you know what
they want to hear on their crappy stray
earbuds or whatever right but I think as
as people you know experienced this and
learn that it's really not that
difficult to find these files it's
difficult to play them back they'll
start making more demands on
manufacturers and more demands on record
companies and more demands of the
content warehouses for delivering these
things and I think we'll see more of it
at least I hope we do um the last thing
about this is that what Neil said was
that they were working on the next
generation ipod right right and that
some rich guy is going to come along do
it well Neal's pretty rich and I'm
pretty sure he's not going to be the guy
to do it but I would love to see what
this new you know hi def ipod looks like
you think it's me like size of it
cake or something like really large no
storage free could be you know store
looks a little it really big yeah a big
steak big ass like boom box on your
shoulder dubby cut it cool I measure
things in terms of cuts of meat actually
so steak iPods ah it's a cigarette so
I'm telling you okay let's get out of
here this is ridiculous this is why we
can't stop talking have a wonderful week
we will see you next week with a product
giveaway and more news from the gadget
lab